triple chinese developer evergrand is
exploring a sale of its property
management firm part of a desperate bid
to sell off assets and raise much needed
cash
the firm evergrand owes more than 300
billion dollars in unpaid bills beijing
is worried about domestic unrest foreign
investors could be the ones left
empty-handed
there's a complete standstill on
evergrants construction sites workers
have long left many unsure if and how
much they get paid for their work
but there might be an end in sight for
the real estate developers crisis that
has shaken investors confidence for
weeks
evergrant is selling a majority stake in
its property management unit for more
than five billion dollars
bringing in much needed cash to carry on
the goal is
to to separate the evergreen group into
three different units and asked the
local government to provide enough money
for for the evergreen group to complete
the projects on hand so that you can
sell the complete flats
to the buyers
and the buyers can pay the evergreen
group who in turn will pay off the
contractors so so that this is for the
as far as the chinese government is
concerned this is the best way forward
and and of course in doing so i think
some creditors will be heard and mostly
overseas creditors
these creditors have known for a while
that their investment is at risk and
still another trading week begins with
markets worrying about possible
contagion and the fallout for china's
entire economy
you